The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to offer
high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or to view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
I guess last time on Friday we
went over the first half of the
class very quickly.
And so today we are going to go
over the second half of the
class very quickly.
And so that was stuff about
double and triple integrals and
vector calculus in the plane and
in space.
As usual, what is on the final
is basically what was on the
other tests, exactly the same
stuff.
Well, not the same problem,
unfortunately.
The first thing we learned
about was double integrals in
the plane and how to set up the
bounds and how to evaluate them.
Just to remind you quickly,
the important thing with
iterated integrals is when you
integrate a function f of x,
y,
say dy dx for example,
is that you have to draw a
picture of a region.
Unless it is completely obvious
you should really draw some
picture of the domain of
integration.
And once you have that picture
you can use it to find the
bounds.
Remember the general method is
that we first look at the inner
integral, here integral of f dy.
And in this inner integral the
outer variable here,
x, is fixed.
That means we are slicing our
region by a vertical line
corresponding to a fixed value
of x.
We fix a value of x.
And what we have to find out is
the bounds for y,
so the value of y at this
point, the value of y at that
point.
Let me call that y some bottom
of x, in general depends on x.
And this one will be y at that
top, and it also depends on x.
And then the bounds for y would
be this.
And then, when you look at the
outer bound, things are
different.
Because there you expect to
have just numbers,
no longer functions of
anything.
And what you do is look at the
shadow of your region.
We are doing it by shadow so
you just project to the x-axis.
If you project to the x-axis
your region will look like this.
Its shadow is going to be this
integral form,
some minimum value of x to some
maximum value of x.
And that will give us the
bounds for the outer integral.
And then, to evaluate,
we evaluate the usual way.
Speaking of evaluation,
what you need to know for the
final,
well, essentially the same kind
of evaluation techniques that we
were supposed to know for the
other tests.
That means the usual functions,
substitutions,
basic trig, stuff like that.
Well, I don't expect that you
would need integration by parts,
although I still hope that some
of you remember it from single
variable calculus.
If there is a need to integrate
some big power of cosine or sine
then the formula will be given
to you the way it is in the
notes.
And, of course,
we know also how to set up
these integrals in polar
coordinates.
And then the area element
becomes r dr d theta.
And because you integrate first
over r,
well, first of all you should
remember the polar coordinate
formulas,
namely x equals r cosine theta
and y equals r sine theta.
And second you should remember
that what we do,
when we have our region,
is for a fixed value of theta
we look for the bounds for r,
just like before,
so the way we are slicing the
region is now we are actually
shooting rays straight from the
origin.
And, in a given direction,
we are asking ourselves how far
does my region go?
You have to find a bound and
you have to find whatever the
value of r will be out here as a
function of theta.
And ways to do that can be
geometric or they can be by
starting from the x,
y equation of whatever curve
you have and then expressing it
in terms of r and theta and
solving for r.
For example,
just to illustrate it,
we have seen that one of our
classics has been the circle of
radius one centered at one,
zero.
This guy, you have two
different ways of getting its
polar coordinate equation.
One is to argue geometrically
that you have a right angle in
here.
And this length is two,
this angle is theta,
this length is r,
so the polar equation is r
equals two cosine theta.
The other way to do it,
if somehow you are missing the
geometric trick,
is to start from the x,
y equation.
What is the x,
y equation of this guy?
Well, it is x minus one squared
plus y squared equals one.
If you expand that you will get
x squared minus two x plus one
plus y squared equals one.
The ones simplify.
X squared plus y squared
becomes r squared minus two x
becomes r cosine theta equals
zero.
That gives you,
when you simplify by r,
r equals two cosine theta.
Two ways to get the same polar
equation.
I should say this is an
example, in case you were
wondering what I was doing.
We have also actually seen how
to change variables to more
complicated coordinate systems.
Let's say u, v coordinates.
But, of course,
you can call them whatever you
want.
The main thing to remember is
that you have to look for the
Jacobian which will give you the
conversion ratio between dx dy
and du dv.
For example,
if you know u and v as
functions of x and y then you
will write du dv equals absolute
value of the Jacobian partial u,
v over partial x, y times dx dy.
Or, if it is easier for you,
you can do the Jacobian the
other way around.
And this Jacobian,
remember, is the determinant by
a two by two matrix that you
obtain by putting the partial
derivatives of u and v with
respect to x and y.
Then, when we have that,
we can change the integrant,
f of x, y, into something
involving u and v possibly.
And then we have to find the
bounds.
And to find the bounds perhaps
the easiest is to draw a picture
of a region in u,
v coordinates.
Maybe you have some picture in
the x,
y plane that might actually be
really hard to draw and maybe in
terms of u and v the picture
will become much simpler.
It might just become a
rectangle.
Of course, if you see
immediately what the bounds are
in terms of u and v,
and they turn out to be very
easy,
then maybe you don't even have
to draw this picture.
But if it is not completely
obvious then that might be a
helpful way of figuring out what
the bounds will be when you
switch from x,
y to u, v.
We have seen some problems like
that and there are more in the
notes in case you need more.
Questions?
Yes?
That is the second time you've
asked for something real quick
in these review sessions.
You are in a hurry.
Take your time.
Partial u, v over partial x,
y is just going to be the
determinant of u sub x,
u sub y, v sub x,
v sub y.
That is the definition.
That is pretty direct.
And, of course,
a general common sense thing
that applies to actually all the
integrals that we are going to
see, there are two things in an
integral.
One is whatever you integral is
called the integrant.
It could be a function here.
It is a vector field in some of
the flux things and so on.
There is another thing which is
the region over which you
integrate.
And the two have strictly
nothing to do with each other.
When you are given a piece of
data in the statement of a
problem,
you have to figure out whether
that is part of a function to be
integrated or whether that is
part of the region of
integration.
If it is the region of
integration then it will go into
the bounds of the integral and
maybe in the choice of the
coordinate system that you use
for integrating.
While the function that you are
integrating goes before the dx
dy and not into the bounds or
anything like that.
I know it sounds kind of silly
but it is a good safety check.
Ask yourselves,
when you have a piece of data,
where in my formula should this
go.
Yes?
I case you want the bounds for
this region in polar
coordinates, indeed it would be
double integral.
For a fixed theta,
r goes from zero to whatever it
is on that curve.
So it would be zero to two
cosine theta of whatever the
function is r dr d theta.
And the bounds on theta would
be from negative pi over two to
pi over two.
We have seen that one several
times, so hopefully by now it is
clearer.
OK.
Let me move on a bit because we
have a lot of other kinds of
integrals to see.
Other kinds of integrals we
have seen are triple integrals.
And I am not doing things in
the order that we did them in
the class just so you can see
parallels between stuff in the
plane and in space.
When we do triple integrals in
space, well, it is the same kind
of story, except now we have,
of course, more coordinate
systems.
We have rectangular
coordinates, we have cylindrical
coordinates and we have
spherical coordinates.
And cylindrical coordinates
only mean that we are,
instead of x, y and z,
we are replacing x and y by the
polar coordinate in the x,
y plane,
so the angle theta and the
distance r.
So R is somehow the distance
from the z-axis and z is the
height.
Usually you don't have to
choose between rectangular and
cylindrical until somewhat late
in the process,
especially if you integrate
first of all z,
because then the choice will
come up mostly when you try to
figure out what are the bounds
for the shadow of your region.
I mean the z part looks exactly
the same in rectangular and in
cylindrical.
Spherical is,
on the other hand,
a little bit more annoying
because it looks quite
different.
You should think of it as doing
polar coordinates not only in
the horizontal direction but
also in the vertical direction
at the same time.
You have this angle phi.
That measures the angle down
from the positive z-axis.
And you have rho which is the
distance from the origin.
And if I project to the z-axis,
r becomes rho sine phi and z
becomes rho cosine phi.
I hope that you all know these
two formulas,
but if you ever have a small
somehow memory lapse during the
final then you should consider
drawing this kind of picture
because it will let you check
very quickly which one is sine,
which one is cosine.
Now, of course,
we have to have formulas for dv
in all these coordinate systems.
Here, for example,
that might be dz r dr d theta
or r dr d theta dz or anything
like that.
Here it might be rho squared
times phi times d rho d phi d
theta.
And the general method for
setting up bounds is pretty much
the same as in the plane,
just there is one more step.
If you are doing rectangular or
cylindrical coordinates with z
first, for example,
that is the most common.
Well, if you do z first then
you have to actually start by
figuring out for a given value
of x and y or r and theta what
is the portion of a vertical
line above x,
y that lies within my region?
That will go from z on the
bottom of my solid which depends
on x and y to z at the top of my
solid which also usually will
depend on x and y.
And so that will give me the
bounds for dz.
And then I will be left with
the shadow of my region in the
x, y plane.
And that one I will set up like
a double integral over there.
Strictly-speaking,
if you are curious,
we could also change to weird
coordinate systems using
Jacobian with three variables at
the same time.
But we haven't seen that so it
won't be on the final.
But it would work just the same
way, just with more pictures to
do.
And, in fact,
I just wanted to say this rho
squared sine phi is actually the
Jacobian for the change of
variables for rectangular to
spherical coordinates.
OK.
Let's not think too much about
that.
Applications.
Well, we have seen how to use
double integrals to find the
area of a volume of a piece of a
plane or a piece of space,
and find also the mass.
Remember, area is just double
integral of one dA,
volume is triple integral of
one dV.
Sometimes if it's the volume
between the x,
y plane and the graph of some
function, you can just set it up
directly as a double integral.
But there is no harm in doing
it as a triple integral if you
feel better about that.
And mass will be double or
triple integral,
depending on how many
dimensions you have,
of whatever density function
you have, dA or dV.
Then there is how to find the
average value of some function.
Well, let me do the
three-dimensional case.
You will just replace volume by
area and dV by dA and so on,
if need be.
That would be one over volume
of the solid times the triple
integral of f dV,
or if it's a weighted average,
one over mass times the triple
integral of a function times
density times dV.
If you don't have a density or
if the density is constant then
that reduces to that one.
In particular,
we have seen the notion of
center of mass.
The center of mass is just
given by taking the average
values of the coordinates,
x bar, y bar,
z bar.
It is just this formula but
taking x, y or z as the
function.
There are moments of inertia.
For example,
the moment of inertia about the
z-axis is the triple integral of
x squared plus y squared density
dV.
Or, if you have just a
two-dimensional object,
it is the same formula,
but, of course,
with dA.
And then we call that the polar
moment of inertia because we
thought of it as rotating the
plane about the origin,
but the origin is just where
the z-axis hits the x,
y plane so it is really the
same thing.
And we have also seen
gravitational attraction in
space, and I will let you look
at your notes for that.
It is just one formula to
remember.
Questions about iterated
integrals, things like that?
Yes?
The formula that you should
know for gravitational
attraction is that if yu have a
point mass at the origin and you
have some solid centered on the
z-axis that is attracting it
then the force will be given by
G times the mass times the
triple integral of density times
cosine phi over rho squared
times dV.
And, of course,
you will actually do that in
spherical coordinates because it
is easier that way.
That is the formula I have in
mind.
But, see, all these formulas
just give you examples of things
to integrate.
And how to set up the bounds
and so on does not depend on
what you are actually
integrating.
It is done always using the
same methods.
Let's move on to work and line
integrals.
We have seen how to do that in
the plane and in space.
And it looks very similar
somehow.
Remember, you have to know how
to set up and evaluate a line
integral of this form.
Let me do it in the plane this
time.
If you are in the plane you
have two components,
and then this becomes the line
integral of M dx plus N dy.
If you have a space curve then
you will have a third component
here.
You will add that guy times dz.
Now, how do we evaluate that?
Well, it is very different from
there because here we are just
on a curve so there should be
only one degree of freedom.
One variable should be enough
to know where we are.
We will have to express x and y
in terms of -- Well,
I should and z optionally if
there is one,
in terms of a single
parameters.
And that might be just one of
the coordinates.
If you are told y equals z
squared, that is easy.
You just substitute y equals x
squared and dy equals two x dx
into everything,
and you are left with an
integral over x.
Maybe it will be something in
terms of time or in terms of an
angle.
We express everything in terms
of a single parameter,
and that will give us a usual
single integral.
Any questions about that?
Yes?
If you cannot parameterize the
curve then it is really,
really hard to evaluate the
line integral.
Well, you might be able to
evaluate it numerically into a
computer, but that is the
easiest way to describe a curve.
Indeed it could be that in the
plane you have an equation in
terms of x and y given by some
completed formulas defining some
curve.
Then actually there are ways
you can use basically
differentials and constrained
partials to figure out what the
tangent vector to the curve is
and so on.
But we haven't really seen how
to do that.
That would be a really nice
topic for tying together the end
of the second unit that we
discussed last time,
constrained partials,
with this stuff.
But that is not going to be
part of our topics.
Basically, all the curves we
have seen in this class,
there is a way to express the
position of a point in terms of
a parameter.
We haven't seen any curves that
are so complicated that you
cannot do that.
The other thing we have seen is
that there are some special
cases of vector fields where we
don't actually have to compute
this thing because maybe we know
that it is the gradient of some
potential function.
And then we have a fundamental
theorem that gives us a way to
compute this without computing
it.
We've seen about gradient
fields and path independence.
The thing to check is whether
the curl of our vector field is
zero.
And remember in the plane that
is one condition,
Nx equals My.
In 3D in space that is actually
three conditions because you
have to check all the mixed
partials of the various
components.
If the curl of f is zero that
tells us we are likely to have a
gradient field.
Strictly-speaking,
I should mention and F is
defined in a simply-connected
region.
Then F is a gradient field.
That means that we can find a
potential function.
You can write F as the gradient
of little f for some potential
function little f.
And we have seen how to find
the potential.
In fact, we have seen two
methods for that.
And we have seen them twice.
We have seen them once for
functions of two variables,
once for functions of three
variables.
They look very much the same.
I encourage you to compare your
notes for the two side by side
to see where they differ.
Where they differ,
roughly-speaking,
well, I never know if it is the
first or the second,
but one of the two methods was
to compute a line integral.
In the plane,
what we did is we set up and
evaluated a line integral along
our favorite path from the
origin to a point with
coordinates say x1,
y1.
And then we had to evaluate the
line integral for the work done
along this path.
And that will give us the value
of potential at that point.
If we are doing it with three
variables, that method remains
very similar.
The only difference is now we
have to go also up in space to
some point x1,
y1, z1.
And so we actually sum three
pieces together.
But on each piece it is the
same story, only one variable
changes.
Here it is only x that changes,
it is only y that changes,
and on the third one only z
would be changing.
That is one possibility.
And the other possibility for
finding the potential is that we
start with the condition that
the first component of our
vector field should be equal to
f sub x for the unknown
potential function.
What we do is integrate with
respect to x,
and we will get our potential
function up to an integration
constant.
And that integration constant
typically depends on the
remaining variables that might
be y or equal in space y and z.
And then what we have to do is
take the partial of this with
respect to y and compare it to
what we want it to be,
namely the y component of a
vector field,
and match them to get some
information about this guy.
And if we have three variables
then there is a third step
because there you will still
have an unknown function of z
that you need to get by
comparing the partials with
respect to z.
I see a lot of very quiet faces
somehow.
Well, hopefully that is because
you know that stuff.
If it is because you are
hopelessly confused then please
review a lot before the final,
but I really hope that is not
the case.
And so,
in particular,
what we have seen is once we
have the potential then we can
use the fundamental theorem of
calculus to tell us that if we
have a line integral to compute
for work along a curve that goes
from some point P zero to some
point P one then the line
integral for the work done by
gradient F is actually going
just to be the change in value
of a potential.
And, in particular,
that does not depend on how we
got from P zero to P one.
That is why we say that we have
path independence.
Next topic is flux in plane and
space.
Flux looks quite different in
the plane and in space because,
in the plane,
it is just another kind of line
integral,
while in space it is a surface
integral.
If you were in four-dimensional
space it would be a triple
integral.
Generally, you do flux for
something that is somehow a wall
that separates regions of space
from each other.
In the plane,
the way we do it is we have a
curve C and we look at its
tangent vector,
let's call that T,
and we rotate it by 90 degrees
clockwise.
That is our convention to get a
unit normal vector that points
to the right of the curve as we
move along the curve.
That is our convention for
orienting curves.
And we are always going to be
using that one.
N equals T rotated 90 degrees
clockwise.
In particular,
that means that n ds,
which will be what we integrate
against when we try to compute
flux, will just end up being dy,
negative dx.
Concretely, when we have to
evaluate a line integral of F
dot n ds,
geometrically we could try to
take the dot product of our
field with the normal vector and
then sum the length element
along the curve.
And, in some cases,
for example,
if you know that the vector
field is tangent to the curve or
if a dot product is constant or
things like that then that might
actually give you a very easy
answer.
But, in general,
the most efficient way to do it
will be to say that if your
vector field has components,
I don't know,
let's call them P and Q,
then that will be just the line
integral of PQ dot dy,
negative dx,
which means negative Q dx plus
P dy.
And, from that point onward,
you evaluate it exactly the
same way as you would for a work
integral.
But, of course,
the geometric meaning is very
different.
It is the same meaning that we
have always seen for flux.
It measures how much a vector
field goes across the curve.
Now, if we are in space then
you take flux for a surface,
not for a curve.
And the way it will work is
that you have to choose an
orientation of a surface,
which just means choosing one
of the two possible unit normal
vectors.
And then you will do a surface
integral for F dot n dS.
That is the surface i element.
The setup for this surface
integral is that first we have
to express n and dS in some way.
One possibility is that we can
express the normal vector n dS
geometrically.
That is, for example,
what we do when we look at,
say, a horizontal plane or a
vertical plane or a sphere or a
cylinder.
Then we have some geometric
idea of why the normal vector is
what it is and we have some
formula for dS.
Or, we can use one of the
standard formulas.
Basically, we have seen two
formulas that work in fairly
generate situations.
One of them says -- If S is
given by an equation z equals
some function of x,
y then you can just say n dS
equals minus f sub x,
minus f sub y,
one, dx dy.
And I need to rewrite that
because I am running out of
space.
But, while I erase,
I would like to point out the
most important there in here.
When I say n dS equals blah,
blah, blah times dx dy,
dx dy is not the same thing as
dS at all.
If you make that mistake you
are going to get into trouble
the next time that you try to
buy real estate in a region
which hills or cliffs or things
like that.
dS is the area on the slanted
surface.
dx dy is the area on the map
that shows the x,
y plane.
And these are not the same
thing.
In particular,
you cannot just take one piece
of it and not the other piece.
Let me give you formulas for n
and for dS separately just to
convince you.
That way, if you feel that you
need them, then you will have
them.
N is minus f sub x,
minus f sub y,
one, but scaled down to unit
length.
This is not a unit vector.
It is actually divided by the
length of this guy which is fx
squared plus fy squared plus
one.
And dS is that same vector
times dx dy.
And so the square roots cancel
out when you multiply them
together.
But it would be completely
wrong to just say I will replace
n dS by minus f sub x,
minus f sub y and one.
Then I end up again with the dS
and I do something else with dS.
That is a pretty bad conceptual
mistake because it gives you the
wrong answer.
Another option more general
than that.
If we have not seen how to
solve for z, how to express z as
a function of x and y,
well, maybe we still know some
normal vector to the surface.
Then there is another formula
for n dS which is up to sine,
N divided by N dot k dx dy.
And, see, that projection
formula works also if you have
to project to another coordinate
plane.
For example,
if you want to project to the
x, z coordinate plane,
the relation between n dS and
dx dz is given by N over N dot
j,
because j is the direction
perpendicular to the xz plane.
But this one is more useful.
What is a good example of that?
If you have a slanted plane
given to you,
you can easily find its normal
vector.
That is just given by the
coefficients of x,
y, z in the equation.
Another situation where that
might happen is if your surface
is given by an equation of a
form of g of x,
y, z equals zero.
If that is the case then you
know this is a level set of g.
And we know how to find a
normal vector to the level set,
namely the gradient vector is
always perpendicular to the
level set.
You would take the gradient of
g to be your big N.
OK.
Now, these are basically all
the integrals we have seen how
to set up.
Now we have a bunch of theorems
relating them.
Let me think about how I am
going to organize that.
Let me try like this.
This part of the board will be
work,
this part of the board will be
about flux and the left part of
the board will be about things
in the plane and the right one
will be about things in space.
What have we seen?
Well, we have seen Green's
theorem for work.
That doesn't work so well
because that is too small,
so I am going to actually use
more blackboards to do that.
This side will be space,
this side will be the plane and
we are going to start with
theorems about work.
And we will see theorems about
flux pretty soon.
We have two theorems about work.
In the plane that is called
Green's theorem.
In space that is called Stokes'
theorem.
Green's theorem says if I have
a closed curve in the plane
going counterclockwise enclosing
entirely some region R then the
line integral along C for the
work of F is equal to the double
integral of a region inside of
the curl of F dA.
Concretely, if my components of
F are called M and N that is the
line integral of M dx plus N dy
is equal to the double integral
of R of N sub x minus M sub y
dA.
This side here is a usual line
integral.
This side here is a usual
double integral in the plane.
And somehow their values end up
being magically related.
Well, not quite magically.
We actually have seen how to
prove it.
And now the analog of that in
space is Stokes' theorem.
Stokes says if I have a closed
curve in space,
now I have to decide what kind
of thing it bounds.
And the answer is it will have
to bound some surface,
but I have a choice of surface.
I choose my favorite surface
bounded by C.
I guess I will just draw it
like that.
And I have to choose a
compatible orientation.
Remember, we have seen this
right hand rule for choosing how
to orient the surface.
I believe, in this case,
if I take C like that then the
normal vector has to go up.
And then it tells me how to
compute the work done by F along
C.
Namely, that becomes the double
integral over that surface S of
curl F, which I will write as
dell cross F dot n dS.
This line integral is a usual
line integral,
but if for some reason we don't
want to compute it directly we
can actually replace it by a
surface integral over any
surface bounded by the curve.
It might be that a problem will
tell you which surface you have
to consider.
It might be that you will be
left to choose the simplest
possible surface you can think
of that is somehow having this
curve as its boundary.
And so now, remember,
curl of a vector field in space
is going to be another vector
expression.
It has three components.
And the way you compute it is
not by remembering the actual
formula,
which is really complicated by,
but by instead computing the
cross-product between dell and
F.
You set up the cross-product.
And, of course,
it is a highly symbolic
cross-product.
I mean it is not an
cross-product of actual vectors
but it works the same way.
Both of these formulas
basically relate work on a curve
with what happens to the curl on
the surface that is enclosed by
this curve,
that is bounded by this curve.
And in this one you have less
freedom of choice because you
don't have somehow a z direction
in which you could move your
surface.
There is only possible choice
of surface.
There is only one thing that is
enclosed by this curve in the
plane.
In both cases,
these things tell you that you
can think of curl as measuring
how much the field fails to be
conservative.
See, if your field was
conservative -- If a curl was
zero then the right-hand side
would just be zero.
And that would be fortunate
because if a curl is zero then
your field is less conservative.
That means it comes from a
potential.
That means when you go along a
closed curve,
well, the change of value of a
potential should be zero.
Another way to say it is path
independence tells you no work.
And, of course,
if you have a vector field that
is not a gradient field then the
curl is not necessarily zero and
then you get a more interesting
answer.
Finally, let's move onto the
theorems about flux.
That is Green for flux and that
is the divergence theorem.
Flux theorems.
Here I say that will be
divergence.
And here it will be Green again.
Green's theorem for flux says I
have a closed curve that goes
counterclockwise around some
region.
In particular,
counterclockwise means that the
normal vector will be going out
of the region.
And then it tells us that the
flux out of the region,
through the curve C,
so that will be the line
integral of F dot n ds is equal
to the integral of a region
inside of div F dA.
And remember the divergence of
M, N is just Mx plus Ny.
This one here,
the divergence theorem,
tells you something similar but
now for a region of space
bounded by a closed surface.
So if you have some region of
space and you call its boundary
surface S and you let n be the
normal vector that goes out of
the region R.
You orient S outwards.
Then the flux out of the region
through S is going to be the
same as the triple integral over
the region of divergence F dV.
Remember, the divergence of a
vector field with components P,
Q, R is Px plus Qy plus Rz.
What do these two theorems say?
Well, they say essentially the
same thing.
They say the total flux out of
a region is equal to the
integral of divergence over
whatever is inside.
And the reason for that is,
again, we have seen for a
velocity field that divergence
measures how much things are
expanding or how much stuff is
being created.
It tells you the amount of
sources per unit portion of the
region.
When you sum that over
everything,
you get the amount of fluid
that is being,
you know, the total amount of
sources inside here,
and that tells us how much
stuff has to go out per unit
time.
That is basically the
interpretation.
In a way, I would be tempted to
say that this table of four
theorems is somehow the crucial
point of 18.02.
And you would do well to
remember them.
However, I would like also to
point out that these theorems
are completely useless if you
don't know how to compute any of
the integrals that are in there.
So all the stuff that was
around there before is actually
somehow more fundamental.
And if you don't know how to
compute the double or triple
integrals then this is of little
use to you.
That is the end.
I guess I have to wish you
happy holidays.